you want to see how tiny I am Frank you
want to stand normally hey guys I'm
Brett Belmont AC producer and today I
will be comparing homemade versus
store-bought donuts I'm ready to take on
our homemade recipe sing parried against
one of America's favorite doughnuts and
correct me if I'm wrong but I believe
that's Krispy Kreme as always we're
gonna be looking into it's worth making
the extra effort and taking the extra
time to make donuts from scratch so
let's get cooking and find out so
today's recipe was initially developed
by Frank when our tasty producers we
begin by activating this creature known
as East this beast should be left alone
to grow for about 10 minutes please have
all your ingredients separate in
temperature this makes incorporating
everything easier trust me you don't
want to try to beat a hard stick of
butter
also quick warning all the mixin may
increase your heart rate side effects
may include development of your biceps
and hand muscles mixing gets easier if
you gradually add the flour so just
consider doing that and just when you
thought the workout was over it's time
to knead and what we do right here is
develop in some look and incorporating
everything so that our dough and Sal
perfect Frank uses a little bit of
vegetable oil to keep our dough fresh
and it works perfectly
I happen to be here with Frank so we go
Instituto actually we gonna let it rest
an hour at room temperature and what's
gonna happen so it's going to double in
size and it should make the dough very
nice and fluffy so it's pretty much
resting and growing twice its size we're
talking about me during the holidays
pretty much
we'll now need it again and refrigerate
it overnight
this nose-down the activity of the yeast
which gives us more control for the
final size of our doughnuts
otherwise your dough keeps growing like
crazy and you could end up with
doughnuts like these I tested a doughnut
and a doughnut hole before throwing
three or four at once just to make sure
that they end up looking like this
fluffy bouncy you get it time to
decorate how do you make the glaze no
worries we included that in our recipe
I also added instructions on how to make
the chocolate ganache including the
classic pink Homer Simpson
[Music]
let's break this down the homemade
version it was a little pricier when he
comes to the time store but wins again
texture-wise you know it really depends
on you but I'm gonna give it to the
store back version now the homemade
version it's not bad at all I mean you
still get fluffiness for the first one
two hours after frying them then after
that it gets a little dense preparation
wise I'm gonna have to go for the store
bought version again here you're gonna
have to deal with the Jo with meeting
with cutting and if it's your first or
second or even the third time it can be
something very complex even more complex
than my accident you know Maxon can get
very tricky so keep that in mind in
terms of looks you know I went around
Instagram these are the percentages that
we got from around 300 people who vote
it comes down to flavor I know you
waited for this so I went around asking
people here at Budds feed 5 out of 6
people said that they would go for the
store but for sure
and I have to agree with that I'm in the
choi factor the melting your mouth
experience that you get from these
donuts and then that glaze come on
you're up for this challenge go for it
homemade is your thing otherwise you're
gonna find me at the store with a couple
of this ones in my purse because
seriously
oh my god guys I'm out here I'm a cute
day see you around
[Music]